Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. In December 1958, the first conference of the Union of African Nations was held at Accra in Ghana. Among the delegations was one from Algeria, representatives of a movement which for four years had been engaged in the bloody war of independence from France. But the Algerian delegates were not interested solely in Algeria. Every African must feel directly engaged and ready to answer the call of any and all territories, one of them declared. An Algerian cannot be a true Algerian if he does not feel in his core
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。1958年12月，非洲国家联盟第一次会议在加纳阿克拉举行。代表团中有一个来自阿尔及利亚，代表了一个四年来一直在进行血腥的独立战争以摆脱法国统治的运动。但阿尔及利亚代表并不仅仅对阿尔及利亚感兴趣。其中一位代表宣称：“每个非洲人都必须感到自己直接参与其中，随时准备响应任何及所有领土的召唤。一个真正的阿尔及利亚人，如果他内心感受不到
the indescribable tragedy that is unfolding in the two Rhodesias or in Angola. And that man, Dominic, was Frantz Fanon, who I guess is, I mean, he's a colossally influential figure, isn't he, on the history of decolonization, and I guess specifically in the African context. Yeah, he is absolutely. So born in Martinique, he's one of the, he becomes one of the emblematic intellectuals of the age of decolonization, with his arguments about blackness and about pan-Africanism and so on. Now, I know what you're thinking, Tom. You think I know nothing about Frantz Fanon. But what you don't know is that my very first work of research was on French colonial Algeria, a subject that Fanon came to know very well.
那场正在两个罗得西亚或安哥拉展开的难以言喻的悲剧，他就不能算是一个真正的阿尔及利亚人。”多米尼克，那个发声的人就是弗朗茨·法农（Frantz Fanon），我想他——我的意思是，他在去殖民化历史上是一个影响巨大的人物，尤其是在非洲语境下。是的，他绝对是。他出生在马提尼克岛，成为了去殖民化时代最具标志性的知识分子之一，他提出了关于黑人性、泛非主义等一系列论点。现在，我知道你在想什么，汤姆。你觉得我对弗朗茨·法农一无所知。但你不知道的是，我的第一篇研究作品就是关于法农非常熟悉的法国殖民统治下的阿尔及利亚。
I wrote a thesis about an anti-Semitic riot in the city of Constantine in Algeria in 1934. Utterly unread, languishes somewhere in a library in Oxford, but I did it. So there you go. So I've managed to turn the conversation from myself which regular listeners regular listeners will know is exactly the spirit in which we conduct this podcast a classic European maneuver very much yeah re-centering Europe yes exactly on what is going to be a discussion about um the process of of African decolonization and it's a fascinating subject though, isn't it?
我写过一篇论文，探讨1934年阿尔及利亚君士坦丁市发生的反犹骚乱。它彻底无人问津，在牛津大学的某个图书馆里落灰，但我确实写过。所以你看。我成功地把谈话的主题从自己身上引开——老听众们都知道，这正是我们主持这个播客的精神内核，一个典型的欧洲式策略。非常正确，是的，重新以欧洲为中心，是的，对吧，这原本将是一场关于……嗯，非洲去殖民化进程的讨论，不过这也是一个迷人的话题，不是吗？
Yeah, and I found it was a remarkable writer. The Wretched of the Earth, I mean, is kind of one of the great kind of foundational texts. But I think one of the things that's interesting about him is the degree to which he's also very French. And because, you know, Martinique was, you know, French colony. And so I wanted to do this topic because uh i read a fantastic essay
是的，我发现他是一位卓越的作家。《大地上的痛苦》可以说是最具奠基意义的伟大文本之一。但我认为他有趣的一点在于，他在很大程度上也非常法国化。因为你知道，马提尼克岛曾是法国的殖民地。所以我之所以想做这个话题，是因为我读了一篇精彩的文章
by um tom o'allade in unheard on fannel and the moment i read it i messaged him and asked him if he would come on and uh elaborate not just about fannel but about the entire history of african decolonization very much for answering the call yes your entire history of african decolonization so very much for answering the call yes your entire history we've got what 50 minutes 40 50 minutes to do that um so thanks so much for for joining us thank you very much for having me so tom could i ask you um december 1958 when um fannel delivers those comments what is the state of play with Africa and the process of decolonisation? Yeah, so in 1958, decolonisation was just at the very early stages. So a year before that, in 1957, the first black African country to gain independence from the British Empire was Ghana with Kwame Nkrumah.
作者是《UnHerd》杂志的汤姆·奥拉德（Tom Owolade），写的正是关于法农的文章。我一读完就给他发了信息，邀请他来节目中详细谈谈，不仅是关于法农，还要谈谈非洲去殖民化的整个历史。非常符合“响应号召”这句话，对吧？是的，你们关于非洲去殖民化的整个历史——我们有大约50分钟，40到50分钟的时间来完成这个任务。非常感谢你能来参加我们的节目。非常感谢邀请我。那么，汤姆，我想问你，1958年12月，当法农发表那些言论时，非洲的现状以及去殖民化进程处于什么阶段？是的，所以在1958年，去殖民化才刚刚处于起步阶段。就在前一年，即1957年，加纳在夸梅·恩克鲁玛（Kwame Nkrumah）的领导下，成为了第一个从大英帝国独立出来的黑非洲国家。
And the year before that, in 1956, two of France's protectorates in Northern Africa, Tunisia and Morocco, gained independence. But by 1945, which I think should be seen as the year in which many anti-colonial leaders really gained confidence they were about only four african countries that could be said to be independent so egypt which which we can dispute but was arguably an independent state by 1945 but very well it had long been under british yeah of course yeah et Yeah, of course, of course, of course. Yeah. Ethiopia as well, which was, of course, occupied during the Second World War by Mussolini's Italy. Liberia, which was founded in the 19th century by ex-African-American slaves, or was founded for, I should say, ex-African American slaves in the 19th century. And also Sierra Leone, which was as well founded to house slaves that were freed after the American Revolutionary War.
而在更前一年，即1956年，法国在北非的两个保护国——突尼斯和摩洛哥获得了独立。但截至1945年——我认为这一年应该被视为许多反殖民地领袖真正获得自信的一年——当时可以说已经独立的非洲国家只有大约四个。也就是埃及——虽然我们可以对此有争议，但到1945年它可以说是一个独立的国家，不过话说回来，它长期受英国……是的，当然，是的。还有埃塞俄比亚，当然，它在二战期间曾被墨索里尼的意大利占领。利比里亚，由前非洲裔美国奴隶在19世纪建立——或者说，我应该说，是在19世纪为前非洲裔美国奴隶建立的。还有塞拉利昂，它同样是为了安置在美国独立战争后获得自由的奴隶而建立的。
South Africa as well was independent because in 1910, South Africa became a dominion within the British Empire, which meant similar to Australia and also Canada, it had independence and was self-governing. So apart from those countries, Africa was colonized, or at least controlled by some other means by European powers. And there's quite a lot of variety in that though, isn't there? So some of these places have, let's say, French Algeria or Kenya or let's say Southern Rhodesia. They have pretty substantial European white settler populations. I mean, Algeria is probably the classic example.
南非也是独立的，因为在1910年，南非成为了大英帝国的一个自治领，这意味着类似于澳大利亚和加拿大，它拥有独立地位并且实行自治。因此，除了这些国家之外，非洲都遭到殖民，或者至少被欧洲列强通过某种其他方式控制着。这里面其实有相当大的多样性，对吧？比如其中一些地方，比方说法属阿尔及利亚、肯尼亚，或者是南罗得西亚，它们都有相当规模的欧洲白人定居者人口。我的意思是，阿尔及利亚可能是最典型的例子。
10% of them are white Europeans. But that's not the case everywhere. So obviously there are quite a lot of colonies where there's a pretty small European presence. And there, I guess, does it depend largely on collaborationist kind of elites? I mean, collaborationist
其中10%的人口是白人欧洲人。但并非所有地方都是如此。显然，在相当多的殖民地，欧洲人的存在感很低。在那些地方，我想，很大程度上要取决于那些买办性质的精英吗？我的意思是，买办
is a very loaded word, but you know what I mean. Does it basically depend... Is the power base of the Europeans always more fragile than it looks, do you think? Definitely. In a country like the Gold Coast, which later became Ghana, it was very much dependent upon the collaboration between the British colonial authorities
是一个非常有倾向性的词，但你明白我的意思。它基本上取决于……你认为欧洲人的权力基础是否总是比它看起来要脆弱得多？绝对是。在一个像黄金海岸（后来的加纳）这样的国家，它在很大程度上依赖于英国殖民当局
and the native African elites, so the businessmen and the lawyers as well. So by 1951, for example, six years before the Gold Coast became independent as Ghana, they were given what was known as responsible self-government. So a constitution granted them responsible self-government. And this was only done because I think by that time, Ghana itself had an emerging upper middle class elite. It was probably the most educated out of all of Britain's West African colonies. So the British could afford to give them a degree of autonomy on that basis. But that's not the case, for example, if we compare that to Congo under the Belgian colonial authority, which was basically ruled from Brussels, essentially,
与本土非洲精英（即商人和律师）之间的合作。因此，举例来说，到1951年，也就是黄金海岸作为加纳独立前六年，他们获得了所谓的“负责任自治”。宪法赋予了他们负责任的自治权。之所以这么做，我认为是因为到那时为止，加纳本身已经崛起了一个中上阶层精英群体。它可能是英国所有西非殖民地中受教育程度最高的。因此，英国人可以在此基础上赋予他们一定程度的自治权。但如果我们把它与对比比利时殖民统治下的刚果进行比较，情况就并非如此了。刚果基本上是由布鲁塞尔直接统治的，
and was a very, very poorly educated colony. So are there radical differences between, say, British colonies, Belgian colonies, French colonies that you can trace? Or do they, are they, I mean, I suppose there's a big difference, say, between Gold Coast and South Africa, as Dominic's pointed out. So with regards to France, the French colonies were treated as a sort of integral part of France itself, essentially.
而且是一个教育极其落后的殖民地。那么，比如说英国殖民地、比利时殖民地、法国殖民地之间，是否存在你可以追踪的根本区别？还是说，它们……我的意思是，正如多米尼克所指出的那样，黄金海岸和南非之间存在着巨大的差异。就法国而言，法国的殖民地被当作法国本土不可分割的一部分来对待。
So Algeria is, isn't it? Algeria is actually the metropolitan part of France. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Exactly. And even the three of the most northern Algerian territories, so Algiers, Iran and Constantine were actually departments of France. They had the same political and legal status as actual territories within metropolitan France. And the other territories as well, so in West Africa, but also in an area known as French Equatorial Africa, they were treated as part of a greater France, essentially. Whereas with the British colonies, they were ruled as individual and independent colonies.
所以阿尔及利亚就是这样，对吧？阿尔及利亚实际上是法兰西本土的一部分。是的，完全正确。完全正确。甚至连阿尔及利亚最北部的三个领土，即阿尔及尔、瓦赫兰和君士坦丁，实际上都是法国的省份。它们拥有与法国本土实际领土相同的政治和法律地位。其他领土也是如此，例如在西非，以及被称为法属赤道非洲的地区，它们基本上都被视为大法国的一部分。而对于英国殖民地，它们则是作为个别且独立的殖民地来统治的。
So they had no sort of relation with each other. But with France, they were all sort of integrated within greater France. And with Belgium, Belgium is an interesting case because before Congo officially became a part of the Belgian colony in 1908, it was essentially the private property of Leopold II, who was one of the most influential figures in the scramble for Africa and he ruled Belgium for about 23 years and he basically used Belgium to extract the natural resources especially in the 1890s when the invention of the pneumatic title led to a massive boom for rubber and his regime is very notorious because half the population of Congo were killed during his 23-year rule. And he's also the figure upon which Kurtz from Joseph Conrad's famous novella, Hearts of Darkness, is based upon. The horror, the horror.
因此它们之间没有任何关联。但对法国而言，它们都融入了大法国之中。比利时则是一个有趣的案例，因为在刚果于1908年正式成为比利时殖民地之前，它基本上是利奥波德二世（Leopold II）的私人财产。利奥波德二世是争夺非洲风潮中最具影响力的人物之一，他统治了比利时大约23年，基本上利用比利时来掠夺自然资源，尤其是在1890年代充气轮胎的发明导致橡胶行业迎来大繁荣的时候。他的政权臭名昭著，因为在他23年的统治期间，刚果有一半的人口被杀害。他也是约瑟夫·康拉德（Joseph Conrad）著名中篇小说《黑暗的心》中库尔茨（Kurtz）这一人物的原型。恐怖啊，恐怖。
Exactly, exactly. Yeah, because that's, I i mean kind of hands being chopped off and yeah yeah people's children being killed if they i mean horrendous so so there's a a wide array of colonial approaches to africa uh by the europeans but by 1958, the foundations are starting to wobble. Yeah. And why is that? Is that due to European weakness or to the growing strength of African determination to obtain autonomy and independence, do you think? What's more important? I think that's probably a case-by-case basis so should we look should we look at at ghana where this you know
没错，没错。是的，因为……我的意思是，砍断双手之类的，还有……是的，是的，如果人们的孩子被杀害的话——我的意思是，太可怕了。所以，欧洲人对非洲的殖民方法有着广泛的差异，但到了1958年，其根基开始动摇了。是的。这是为什么呢？你认为这是由于欧洲的软弱，还是由于非洲人争取自治和独立的决心日益增强？哪个更重要？我认为这大概需要根据具体情况来看。那么，我们是否应该看看加纳——在这个国家，你知道的，
this this um first conference of the union of african nations is being held in 1958 yeah so so what's the what's the the process by which ghana becomes independent from Britain? In 1947, there was a new party that was created in Ghana. And this party was known as the United Gold Coast Convention. And it was a party which consisted of native African elites, so businessmen and lawyers. And the leader of that party was a man called Joseph Dwanqua. And Dwanqua was, I believe, the first Black African to actually qualify as a barrister in the Inner Temple in London. So this party consisted largely of westernised Native Africans. And the party was created so that the British could develop a path by which the Gold Coast can gradually become a self-governing country within the British Empire and possibly become independent eventually. was created, one of the leaders of the parties or one of the organisers of the parties split off when created his own party. And this organiser within the party was Kwame Nkrumah, who later
非洲国家联盟的第一届会议于1958年举行。是的，那么加纳从英国独立的进程是怎样的？1947年，加纳成立了一个新政党。这个政党被称为“联合黄金海岸公会”（United Gold Coast Convention）。这是一个由本土非洲精英（即商人和律师）组成的政党。该党的领袖是一个名叫约瑟夫·丹夸（Joseph Danquah）的人。我相信，丹夸是第一个真正在伦敦内殿律师学院获得大律师资格的黑非洲人。因此，这个政党主要由西化的本土非洲精英组成。该党成立的初衷是让英国人开辟一条途径，使黄金海岸逐渐成为大英帝国境内一个实行自治的国家，并最终可能实现独立。成立后不久，该党的一位领袖兼组织者脱离出去，创建了自己的政党。党内的这位组织者就是夸梅·恩克鲁玛，他后来
became the first Prime Minister of Ghana. So prior to joining this party in 1947, Nkrumah lived for over a decade abroad. He was in America studying sociology, economics and philosophy, but he was largely impoverished during this time. And he even spent some time in New York selling fish. And he also later moved to London to study law. And he spent most of his time time rather than actually getting his law degree arguing with communists and anti-colonialists in Camden cafes. Never go to Camden, that's the last one. Definitely. So in 1949 Nkrumah split off from the United Gold Coast Convention to set up
成为了加纳的第一任总理。因此，在1947年加入这个政党之前，恩克鲁玛曾在国外生活了十多年。他在美国学习社会学、经济学和哲学，但这段时间他大部分时间都穷困潦倒。他甚至还在纽约卖过一段时间鱼。后来他又搬到伦敦去学法律。但他大部分时间不是去拿法律学位，而是在卡姆登的咖啡馆里与共产主义者和反殖民主义者争论。千万别去卡姆登，这是最后一次警告。绝对的。所以在1949年，恩克鲁玛脱离了“联合黄金海岸公会”，建立了自己的
his own party and the priority for Nkrumah was not independence as a gradual process. He wanted independence now. He was later imprisoned by the Governor General of the Gold Coast, Charles Arden Clark, for incitement and sedition. During his imprisonment, he actually won an election. So in 1951, there was an important election in the Gold Coast, which Nkrumah won, and which basically demonstrated to the British authorities that independence was basically around the corner. So let me ask you two things.
政党。对恩克鲁玛来说，当务之急不是把独立当作一个渐进的过程。他想要立即独立。后来，他被黄金海岸总督查尔斯·阿登-克拉克（Charles Arden-Clark）以煽动罪和煽动叛乱罪投入大狱。在狱中，他竟然赢得了一场选举。因此，在1951年，黄金海岸举行了一场重要的选举，恩克鲁玛赢得了胜利，这基本上向英国当局表明，独立已经指日可待了。那么，我想问你两件事。
I can see Tom wants to butt in, so I'm going to ask two questions to stop him. The first one is about education. So Nkrumah has gone to New York, and I think he studied in Pennsylvania before he went to New York, Lincoln University, and then he goes to the LSE. And if you look, a lot of these African independence leaders in the 50s and 60s, an awful lot of them have studied abroad
我看出汤姆想插话，所以我要提出两个问题来阻止他。第一个问题关于教育。恩克鲁玛去了纽约，我想他在去纽约之前还在宾夕法尼亚州的林肯大学（Lincoln University）学习过，然后去了伦敦政治经济学院（LSE）。如果你观察一下，50和60年代的许多非洲独立领袖，有相当多的人都在国外或在宗主国学习过。
or studied in the metropolis. And I wondered awful lot of them have studied abroad or studied in them in the metropolis and i wondered if you could talk a bit about the influence of that and then how representative that makes them of of of of the people they want to lead basically and then the second issue is about one thing we haven't talked about is the second world war and that presumably that had a shattering effect on these, on the self-confidence of the Europeans, but also the confidence of the African, well, the African population now knew that these people weren't,
或者在宗主国学习过。我想知道，你是否能谈谈这种经历的影响，以及这使得他们在多大程度上能够代表他们基本上想要领导的人民？第二个问题是关于——我们一直没有谈到的一点是第二次世界大战。这presumably（想必）对欧洲人的自信心产生了粉碎性的影响，同时也对非洲人的自信心——好吧，非洲人民现在知道这些人并非——
I mean, if they'd ever thought it, that these people are beatable. You know, they're not superheroes. They have feet of clay and they've been humiliated by the Japanese, for example. So there's two things there. Can you say something about those two? yeah and then tom can never speak again tom yeah yes i know my place um so so during the um the interwar period yes many um anti-colonial leaders moved to the us and the uk to study and i and i think this this relates moved to the US and the UK to study. And I think this relates actually to the
我的意思是，如果他们以前有过这种想法的话——这些人是可以被打败的。你知道，他们不是超级英雄。他们也有泥足，而且他们曾被日本人羞辱过，比如说。所以这里有两个问题。你能就这两点谈谈吗？是的，然后汤姆就再也不能说话了。汤姆。是的，我知道我的位置。那么，在两次世界大战期间，许多反殖民主义领袖移居美英两国学习。我认为这实际上与
notion of Pan-Africanism. What many people, I'm not sure, understand is that Pan-Africanism is in many respects a Western concept. So the very first Pan-African conference, for instance, was actually held in London in 1900. And it wasn't actually organized by an African. It was organized by a West Indian man called Henry Sylvester Williams. And pan-African congresses were held in Paris, London, New York, and Manchester before they actually reached an African city. So the very first Pan-African conference that was held in Africa wasn't until 1974. Wow, that's amazing.
泛非主义的概念有关。许多人——我不确定——所不了解的是，泛非主义在许多方面是一个西方概念。例如，第一次泛非会议实际上于1900年在伦敦举行。它甚至不是由非洲人组织的。它是由一个名叫亨利·西尔维斯特·威廉姆斯（Henry Sylvester Williams）的西印度群岛人组织的。泛非大会在巴黎、伦敦、纽约和曼彻斯特举行，之后才真正到达非洲城市。因此，在非洲举办的第一届泛非会议直到1974年才举行。哇，太惊人了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's incredible. In Dar es Salaam. So when these anti-colonial leaders moved to major Western cities, they were also interacting with West Indian thinkers and intellectuals as well. So like Fanon? Yeah, so like Fanon, but also like, for instance,
是的，是的，是的。这太不可思议了。在达累斯萨拉姆。因此，当这些反殖民主义领袖移居西方主要城市时，他们也在与西印度群岛的思想家和知识分子进行交流。就像法农那样？是的，就像法农，还有比如
C.L.R. James in London. So they were interacting with these West Indian thinkers and intellectuals. And incidentally, Marcus Garvey never visited Africa in his life. And Garvey was one of the most influential Pan-African leaders. So to that extent, many of these anti-colonial leaders were to a significant extent westernized and they were westernized to an extent um that sort of that essentially distinguished them from the native population of the country from from which they came from because most most of the population
伦敦的C.L.R.詹姆斯（C.L.R. James）。因此，他们与这些西印度群岛的思想家和知识分子进行交流。顺便说一句，马库斯·加维（Marcus Garvey）一生从未访问过非洲。而加维是最具影响力的泛非主义领袖之一。从这个程度上讲，许多反殖民主义领袖在很大程度上是西化的，他们的西化程度……在某种程度上，这基本上使他们区别于他们所出身的国家的本土人口，因为绝大多数人口——
most of the population populations in the countries from which they came were largely illiterate and they couldn't speak the European languages and I think one of the most distinctive qualities of many of these post-colonial and anti-colonial African leaders was their fluency
他们出身的国家的绝大多数人口基本上是文盲，他们不会说欧洲语言。我认为这些后殖民和反殖民非洲领袖最鲜明的品质之一，就是他们的流利表达
and was their charisma. Somebody like Leopold Seda Senghor was both an influential figure within the negritude movement in 1930s Paris, but also became the first president of Senegal. And he was elected a fellow of the Académie Française, wasn't he? Yeah, the first black African to be elected
和个人魅力。像利奥波德·塞达尔·桑戈尔（Leopold Sedar Senghor）这样的人，既是1930年代巴黎黑人觉醒运动（Negritude movement）中的影响力人物，后来也成为了塞内加尔的第一任总统。他甚至被选为法兰西学术院（Academie francaise）的院士，对吧？是的，他是第一个被选为法兰西学术院成员的黑非洲人。
a member of the Académie Française. And he was also the first person to pass aggregation which which is like um a very competitive exam um that allows you to become a teacher in france he was also um a school teacher in france during the 1930s um and also a poet as well i mean we we opened with fanner and i commented on when when i read him i mean he feels to me incredibly french yes so many of his attitudes his assumptions his arguments are strange nouns and you mentioned clr james you know this is brilliant um right from the caribbean and i read him because he writes about cricket and I the first when I read him when I was young I thought oh this is you know he's very radical you know this is most unlike any writing about cricket I've ever read and I read him again recently and I thought god this
他也是第一个通过“法国高校教师资格会考”（aggregation）的人——这就像是一场竞争非常激烈的考试，通过后可以成为法国的老师。他在1930年代也曾是法国的一名学校老师，同时也是一位诗人。我的意思是，我们以法农开场，当我读到他的作品时，我评论过——在我的感觉里，他极其法国化。是的，他的许多态度、假设、论点——奇怪的名词，你提到了C.L.R.詹姆斯，你知道，这太棒了……直接来自加勒比海，我读他的作品是因为他写板球，我年轻时第一次读的时候，心想，哦，这（你知道的）非常激进，你知道，这与我读过的任何关于板球的文字都不同。而我最近又读了一遍，心想，天哪，这家伙是个英国人！他一直在喋喋不休地谈论W.G.格雷斯（WG Grace）。我想，如果你来自加勒比海，这大概是真的，因为他们受英国和法国帝国主义传统的塑造时间要长得多。而在非洲，你知道，英国和法国……他们来自伦敦、巴黎、纽约的大学，是的。所以，你的意思是——把摆脱西方统治的去殖民化动力本身说成是相当西化的，这会是一种夸张吗？嗯，我认为这样说是正确的，因为甚至连……的概念，这又回到了
guy's British he's going on about WG Grace all the time and and I guess that's kind of probably true if you're coming from the Caribbean because they've been shaped for so much longer by British and French traditions of imperialism. And Africa, you know, the period of British and French them is coming from the universities of london paris new york yeah so do you i mean would it be an exaggeration to say that the impetus for decolonization from western rule is itself pretty western um i i think that that would be a correct thing to say because even the notion of and this links to
你的书，汤姆。别这样，谢谢你。但普世人权的概念是……我想他拿到了普世人权的最高荣誉……
your book again Tom don't do this thank you but the notion of universal human rights is he had a I think he got a kind of highest distinction of universal human rights is...
好吧，恩克鲁玛有……我想他在神学方面获得了最高荣誉，对吧？是的，是的。有趣的是，恩克鲁玛受洗成为了一名天主教徒，并且
Well, Nkrumah had a... I think he got the highest distinction in theology, didn't he? Yeah, yeah. And interestingly enough, Nkrumah was baptised a Catholic and he
他认真考虑过成为一名耶稣会神父，但后来……政治介入了。通过其他途径实现的基督教。是的，绝对的，绝对的。恩克鲁玛也对英国文化的许多方面着迷。因此，当他在1957年成为加纳总理时，他实际上拜访了巴尔莫拉尔城堡的英国女王，并且拍了一张
seriously considered becoming a Jesuit priest, but then politics. Christianity by other means. Yeah, definitely, definitely. And Nkrumah as well was also besotted by many, many aspects of British culture. So when he became Prime Minister of Ghana in 1957, he actually visited the Queen in Balmoral, and a picture
两人的合影，直到他去世那天，那张恩克鲁玛和女王的照片都是他最珍视的财产之一。嗯，《王冠》（The Crown）里有一个非常——我认为被夸大了的桥段，你看过吗？——恩克鲁玛和女王跳舞那一幕。多米尼克，你看过这个吗？他鄙视王冠……我认为那是夸张的，但我的意思是，我想那是那种经历。不过，说到宗教这个话题，多米尼克，我只是觉得——这太有汤姆·霍兰德式的发言了——但但但但但——有一种西方式的，你知道的，后法国大革命时期的普世主义，
was taken of both of them until the day he died. That picture of Nkrumah and the Queen was one of his most prized possessions. Well, there's that um very um i think exaggerated sequence in the crown have you seen that where and krumer and the queen dance dominic watch this he he despises the crown um i think that's exaggerated but i mean i guess that's the kind of experience but what just on the topic of um of religion it dominic i just that's such a tom holland thing to say but but but but but there's there's there's there's there's there's kind of western type you know post-french
是的，它融入了马克思主义，这在这一时期显然对许多非洲领袖具有极大的吸引力。但你确实也拥有伊斯兰教和基督教的普世主义，它们也相当重要。当我研究《自治领》（Dominion）时，我发现真正有趣的事情之一，就是发现埃塞俄比亚作为（你知道的）罗马之前第一个基督教国家是多么重要。是的。以及它的起源可以一直追溯到所罗门和示巴女王的这种意识，
revolutionary uh universalism and yeah you know which feeds into marxism and that obviously is a kind of a very appealing to lots of african leaders in this period but you do also have the universalisms of Islam and Christianity, and they're also quite important. And one of the things I thought was really interesting when I was researching Dominion was to discover how important Ethiopia was as, you know, the first Christian nation before Rome. Yes. And the sense that its origins go all the way back to Solomon and the Queen of
以及它能够一直追溯到所罗门和示巴女王的意识。这种它保留了独立地位，因此能够为非洲民族主义者和非洲基督徒提供一种并非来自欧洲的灵感的意识。这似乎具有某种显著性和重要性，在我开始阅读之前，我并没有完全理解这一点。是的，是的。埃塞俄比亚在泛非主义的概念中发挥了不可或缺的作用。因此，你甚至可以在拉斯塔法里教（Rastafarianism）中看到这种传统的遗迹，这是一种泛非主义理想与对埃塞俄比亚君主海尔·塞拉西（Haile Selassie）等人的崇拜相融合的产物——是的，完全正确。是的。尽管甚至曾有一段时间，黑人被称为“埃塞俄比亚人”——或者说“埃塞俄比亚人”或类似称呼。我认为这再次指代了埃塞俄比亚在集体黑人身份中所发挥的不可或缺的作用。我认为这就是为什么埃塞俄比亚在第二次世界大战期间在墨索里尼的猛烈进攻下存活下来，
Sheba and the sense that it had go all the way back to Solomon and the Queen of Sheba. And this sense that it had preserved its independence and therefore could provide a kind of inspiration to both to kind of African nationalists and to African Christians that did not come from Europe. And that seemed to have a kind of salience and importance that I hadn't properly understood until I began reading that. Yes, yes. Ethiopia played an integral role in the concept of Pan-Africanism. So you can even see a legacy of that in Rastafarianism, which is a sort of a melange of Pan-Africanist ideals with with with a sort of worship of ethiopian monarchy harley slassie and yeah exactly yeah and and even though there was even a time when to call the black but when black people were referred to as ethiopians or yeah or etopians or something like that and I think that refers to again the sort of
对非洲的去殖民化如此重要。因为你可以看到双重极点，即古代非洲文明对抗这个声称自己是罗马帝国复兴的欧洲超级大国，基本上就是这样，而非洲文明存活了下来。是的。在我们进入休息之前，我有一个问题。我刚才关于第二次世界大战的最后一个问题，被汤姆·霍兰德非常巧妙地引开，又回到了他的书和宗教主题上。所以我们先把第二次世界大战放一边，因为我要问的问题是：这其中很大一部分都关乎精英，关乎那些受过极高教育的人，他们去过——你知道的，他们受埃塞俄比亚例子的影响，在20多岁和30多岁时因为上大学而发生了转变，他们在卡姆登与共产主义者交谈，做着许多诸如此类见不得光的事情，然后带着受到泛非理想启发的心态回来了。我的问题是：其他人呢？因为显然去殖民化部分是由群众集会、
integral role Ethiopia played in a sort of collective black identity I think that's why Ethiopia surviving the onslaught of Mussolini during the Second World War
抗议运动、叛乱等推动的。究竟是什么解释了——我的意思是，这不可能像对自由的普遍渴望那么简单——但究竟是什么让所有这些人游行、高呼口号，并团结在夸梅·恩克鲁玛以及像他这样的人和其他殖民主义者身后呢？嗯，就夸梅·恩克鲁玛而言，他基本上——实际上，我认为恩克鲁玛有趣的地方在于，尽管他去过西方并上了许多精英大学，但他实际上并非出身于
was I think so important to African decolonization. Because you sort of see the twin poles, the sort of ancient African civilization against this European superpower that claims to be a sort of resurrection of the Roman Empire, basically, and the African civilization survived. Yeah. Just before we go to a break, I have a question. The last question I asked about the Second World War, Tom Holland very deftly steered it away from back to his book
新兴城市工人阶层，本质上是工会成员、城市里的学校老师，而不一定是一国的精英。因此，恩克鲁玛基本上能够塑造平民领袖的形象，而不是某种高高在上的遥远精英，所以他能够参与这种形式的民粹主义——我认为用这个词来形容很准确。他也是某种“知心大哥”。关于恩克鲁玛，一个有趣的事情是，在1950年代，许多人实际上会拜访他的住所，征求关于他们可以从事什么工作的建议，也向他咨询婚姻方面的问题。天哪，这种参与度。
and the subject of religion. So let's park the Second World War for a second, because the question I have to ask, so much of this has been about elites, about very highly educated people who've gone, you know, who are influenced by the example of Ethiopia, who have been transformed by being at universities in their 20s and 30s, who've been talking to communists in Camden, doing lots of dodgy things like that, and have come back inspired with Pan-African ideals. My question is, what about everybody else? Because obviously decolonization is partly driven by mass meetings,
是的，这是我们这个播客尚未探索的一个维度。想象一下对鲍里斯（Boris）这样做。想象一下去唐宁街10号向鲍里斯征求婚姻建议。那太糟糕了。有趣的是，恩克鲁玛当时并未结婚。与许多其他非洲
protest movements, insurgencies, and so on. What is it that explains, I mean, it can't be as simplistic as a generalized desire for freedom but but what is it that gets all these people marching and and chanting and and rallying behind kwame and krumer and and people like him and other colonists um so with with kwame um and krumer he was basically um actually, I think the interesting thing about Nkrumah was that even though he went to the West and attended many elite universities, he actually came from not a of emerging urban workers, essentially. So the trade unionists, school teachers in cities, rather than necessarily the elites of the country. So Nkrumah was basically able to cultivate the persona of a man of the people rather than a sort of distant elite so he was able to sort of
领袖不同，他的私生活非常单纯，甚至带有一点清教徒色彩。他本来要成为一名耶稣会士的，不是吗？是的，是的，是的。一点也不奇怪。我想我们该休息一下了。我认为当我们回来时，我们应该看看伴随着权力的移交而发生的暴力事件。
engage in that form of populism which i think is an accurate way to describe it and he was also a sort of agony aunt as well so so an interesting thing about in krumer was that many people actually visited his residence during the 1950s, asking for advice about what kind of job they can do and also asking for him advice on marital problems as well. Goodness, that's a level of engagement. Yeah, that's an element of this podcast we've yet to explore. Imagine doing that with Boris.
所以，你知道，相当一部分——英国人尤其擅长那些浮华的仪式，比如米字旗降下，新国旗升起。同样，法国人也非常擅长制造“法语圈”（la Francophonie）的概念，营造出仿佛什么都没有发生重大改变的印象。但当然，其中确实存在非常、非常暴力的例外。所以让我们来看看这个。然后也许我们可以看看刚果，我的意思是，它在某种程度上是其中最残暴的一个。所以休息过后，我们将回归这一话题。
Imagine going to number 10 and ask Boris for marital advice. That would be terrible. Which is funny because Nkrumah was not married during that time. And unlike many other African
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐之巅》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、
leaders, he had a very sort of chaste and slightly puritanical private life. He was going to become a Jesuit, wasn't he? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Not surprised. I think we should take a break. And I think when we come back, we should look at the violence that surrounded quite a lot of the transfer of power.
独家加更节目以及抢先获得现场演出门票的机会，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正与汤姆·奥拉德一起讨论非洲去殖民化。我们一直在谈论精英，谈论卡姆登的咖啡馆，现在我们要谈谈暴力。因为显然，这通常是一个非常暴力的过程，不是吗？去殖民化的过程。
So, you know, quite a lot. The British particularly were quite adept at the flummery of, you know, the Union Jack coming down and the new flag going up. And likewise, the French were very good at kind of manufacturing the idea of the francophonie and the idea that nothing much had greatly changed. But of course, there really were very, very violent exceptions to that. So let's look at that. And then perhaps could we look at Congo, which is, I mean, in a way, the most brutal of the lot. So we will be back with that after the break.
典型的例子，比如阿尔及利亚。我想肯尼亚会是英国最明显的例子。它并不总是暴力的，但是——你认为暴力在什么时候更容易发生？当有大量白人定居者人口时，暴力会更有可能发生吗？是的，是的，我认为在两个典型的例子中绝对是这样的——阿尔及利亚，还有肯尼亚。就阿尔及利亚而言，我想——因为你在开始时说过，阿尔及利亚10%的人口来自欧洲，所以是欧洲定居者，即黑脚党（pieds noirs）。我认为最引人注目的是，在阿尔及利亚最大的城市阿尔及尔，欧洲人口占了该市的三分之一。所以他们有巨大的存在感。阿尔贝·加缪（Albert Camus）这样的人，我的意思是，他是最著名的例子。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening,
是的，完全正确。而且有趣的是，他们中的许多人——因为有些人可能会有一种看法，认为许多所谓的“黑脚党”或欧洲定居者来自法国。而事实上，其中许多人很贫穷，他们来自其他欧洲地中海国家。比如西班牙、希腊、意大利。甚至加缪的母亲也有一部分西班牙血统，我相信是这样的。但我认为定义许多“黑脚党”的关键在于他们抗拒任何形式的去殖民化，或者抗拒任何脱离法国独立的企图。罗得西亚也是如此，对吧？显然，还有南非……是的，完全正确，很复杂。是的，我认为这部分是出于对作为少数群体生活在多数本土国家中的恐惧，以及遭到某种报复的可能性——不幸的是，阿尔及利亚和罗得西亚都是如此。所以双方绝对都存在暴力行为。因此，在阿尔及利亚，暴力的最著名典型例子就是法国殖民当局实施集体惩罚的方式。
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about African decolonization with Tom Owolade. And we have been talking about elites. We've been talking about Camden coffee shops. And now we're going to talk about violence. Because obviously, this was often a very violent process, wasn't it? The process of decolonization.
因此，所有阿拉伯人和柏柏尔人基本上都被隔离在城市的某些区域内。任何被怀疑煽动叛乱或恐怖主义的人都会遭到残酷的虐待。但从1955年左右开始，民族解放阵线（FLN），即阿尔及利亚独立运动背后的游击队组织——法农也曾属于这个组织，对吧？——是的，他也曾属于该组织。他们也将居住在那里的欧洲平民区作为明确的袭击目标。
The classic examples, places like Algeria. I suppose Kenya would be the most obvious british one it's not always violent but but when when is it that you think is it is is violence more likely when there are big populations of white settlers do you think yeah yeah i think that definitely um is the case in the two classic examples so um algeria and also kenya as well so with with algeria i i think um because you said at the beginning that algeria 10 percent of of algeria um algeria's population came from europe so were european settlers the uh pied noir i think i think the striking thing was that in Algiers, which was the biggest city in Algeria, the European population was a third of the city. So they had a massive presence. The people at Albert Camus, I mean, he's the most famous example.
电影《阿尔及利亚之战》中那些人们在咖啡馆里安放炸弹的著名场景，就是这样的，对吧？是的，完全正确。一部关于暴力及其困难的精彩电影，实际上。这部电影上映
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Definitely, definitely. And interestingly enough, many of them, because I think the perception some people might think is that many of the sort of pieds noirs, European settlers, came from France. And one of these elites who actually meant many of them were poor and they came from other European Mediterranean countries. So Spain, Greece, Italy as well. Even Camus' mother was partly Spanish, I believe, or had Spanish ancestry. But I think the key thing that defined many of the Pierre Noir was resistance to any sort of decolonisation or any sort of independence away from france and the same was true in rhodesia wasn't it and obviously i mean in south africa yeah exactly complicated yeah yeah and i think that was partly motivated by fear of living as a minority in a majority um native country and the sort of the possibility of any sort of retribution, which was the case in both Algeria and also in Rhodesia, actually, unfortunately. So there was definitely violence on both sides. So in Algeria, the most famous classic examples of the violence was the way in which collective punishment was meted out by the French colonial authorities.
是在1966年，也就是战争结束仅仅四年之后。它在法国被禁映了大约五年。我的意思是，《大地上的痛苦》——法农的这本巨著的论点恰恰是，如果要抛弃欧洲殖民主义，就必须诉诸暴力，
So all the Arab and Berber populations were essentially quarantined within parts of the city. And anyone suspected of sedition or terrorism was violently tortured. But there was also, from about 1955, the FLN, which was the guerrilla organisation behind the Algerian independence movement. To which Fanon belonged, right? Yeah, he belonged to as well. Also targeted, specifically targeted, civilian areas with European people
因为法农认为殖民主义和帝国主义的本质就是暴力的，所以应对它的唯一充分手段就是通过暴力方式。好了，这就把我们带到了刚果——这也是最臭名昭著的欧洲殖民主义最糟糕的例子，我想你会说——这并不是巧合，它在独立时的命运也同样糟糕。是的，与刚果的许多其他殖民地不同，
living there. Well, there's those famous scenes in the film The Battle of Algiers, of the people planting the bombs in the cafes, aren't there? Yeah, exactly. A brilliant film, actually, about the violence and the difficulty of it. And the film was released
当地的黑人人口在独立之前被禁止成为律师、医生或建筑师。他们也被禁止在军队中获得任何高级职位。因此，当地人口不仅在政治上被剥夺了权利，而且被剥夺了任何获得权力的途径。所以当刚果独立时，没有能够成功引领国家走向某种繁荣甚至可持续发展的公民社会，因为当地人口绝大多数是文盲，而且比利时人就只是收拾行李走人了——
only in 1966, so literally just four years after the war ended. And it was actually banned in France for about five years. And I mean, the argument of Wretched of the Earth, Fanon's great book is precisely that there needs to be violence if European colonialism is going to be cast off yeah because fanon thought that the um nature of colonialism and imperialism was violent by its very nature so the only adequate response to it was through violent means okay which which brings us to to congo yeah which is notoriously the worst example of european colonialism and i guess you would say i mean it's not a coincidence then that that it's which is notoriously the worst example of European colonialism. And I guess you would say, I mean, it's not a coincidence then that its fate in independence is kind of awful as well. Yeah, so in contrast to many other colonial states in Congo,
是的，是的——我的意思是，当你真正阅读时间线时，这简直难以置信。他们大约在1959年含糊其辞地谈论离开，然后在1960年1月开会说他们将在夏天离开，再见，你知道的，你们自己看着办吧。是的，而且——甚至在比利时国王当时发表的最后演讲中，当时的国王博杜安（King Baudouin）基本上还称赞了利奥波德二世将比利时人带到了刚果。而帕特里斯·卢蒙巴（Patrice Lumumba）在随后的演讲中说：“我们不再是你们的猴子了。”
the native black population were, before independence, they were forbidden to become lawyers or doctors or architects. And they were also forbidden to gain any sort of senior position in the military. So the population was not only sort of disenfranchised politically, but they were forbidden any sort of route to gaining power. So when the Congo became independent, there was no civil society that was able to sort of successfully carry the country to any sort of prosperity or even sustainability, because the population was largely illiterate but also the belgians just they just pack up and go yeah yeah yeah i mean it's unbelievable when you actually
所以给我们讲讲卢蒙巴吧，他是谁？他从哪里来？因为他是一个关键且悲剧性的人物，他是伟大的烈士，对吧？是的，是的，他是去殖民化运动中的伟大烈士，
read the timeline they're sort of vaguely talking about leaving in 1959 they have a meeting in january 1916 they say we're off in the summer goodbye you know fend for yourselves yeah and and and and even like during the um final speech the um the king of king of Belgium at that time, King Padua, basically praised King Leopold II for bringing the Belgians to Congo. And Patrice Lumumba in his speech after said, we are not your monkeys anymore. Yeah. So tell us about Lumum lamumba um yeah who is he where's he coming from because he's he's a key and and tragic figure he's the great martyr isn't he yeah yeah yeah he's the great martyr of of of decolonization uh you could you
你可以合乎情理地这样说。卢蒙巴出生于1925年——说来有趣，这一年也是法农出生的年份。他成为了一名工会成员，到1960年时，他成为了刚果某个特定政党的领袖。我认为重要的是要强调，刚果是一个幅员辽阔的国家，在通往刚果独立的选举中，有许多政党在竞争。卢蒙巴只是庞大阵营中的一个。因此，他基本上必须处理一个联合政府。
could plausibly say um so lamumba was born in um 1925 which um funny enough was also the year that Fanon was born in um and and he he became a sort of trade unionist and and by 1960 he was a leader of of a particular party in Congo I I think what's important to emphasise is that Congo was a vast country and there were many parties competing during the elections that led to Congo's independence. And Lumumba was just one of a vast array. So he had to handle a coalition, basically.
因此，到1960年6月下旬，卢蒙巴成为了独立刚果的第一任总理。而非行政总统是一个名叫约瑟夫·卡萨武布（Joseph Kasa-vubu）的人，他后来发挥了重要作用。在这个时期，当卢蒙巴成为总理时，他的国务秘书是一个名叫约瑟夫-德西雷·蒙博托（Joseph-Desiree Mobutu）的人。而蒙博托在成为卢蒙巴的私人秘书之前是一名记者，但在此之前他曾在刚果武装部队服役，不过他只被允许担任卑微的职位。他不被允许在军阶上晋升，因为黑非洲人被明确禁止这样做。因此，到1960年6月下旬，卢蒙巴成为了总理，但两种形式的危机即将吞噬他。第一场危机是由刚果武装部队发动的哗变，因为他们基本上仍然主要是白人，而且从一开始就反对卢蒙巴。
And so by late June of 1960, Lumumba becomes the first prime minister of an independent Congo. And the non-executive president was a man called Joseph Kasafubu, who would later play an influential role. And in this time, Lumumba's Secretary of State, when he became Prime Minister, was a man called Joseph Desiree Mobutu. And now Mobutu, before he became Lumumba's Private Secretary, he was a journalist, but before that he served in the Congolese armed forces, but he was only allowed to serve in lowly positions. He wasn't allowed to ascend through the ranks because that was explicitly forbidden for Black Africans. So by late June 1960, Lumumba was prime minister, but two forms of crisis were about to engulf him. The first crisis was the mutiny led by the Congolese armed forces, because they were still largely white, essentially, and they were opposed to Lumumba from the start.
因此，到1960年6月下旬，卢蒙巴成为了独立刚果的第一任总理。而非执行总统是一个名叫约瑟夫·卡萨武布的人，他后来将发挥重要作用。在这一时期，卢蒙巴担任总理时的国务秘书是一个名叫约瑟夫·德西雷·蒙博托的人。而蒙博托在成为卢蒙巴的私人秘书之前是一名记者，但在此之前他曾在刚果武装部队服役，不过他只被允许担任低级职务。他不被允许晋升，因为这明确禁止黑人非洲人。因此，到1960年6月下旬，卢蒙巴担任总理，但两场危机即将吞噬他。第一场危机是由刚果武装部队领导的兵变，因为他们本质上仍然主要是白人，并且从一开始就反对卢蒙巴。
So Lumumba dismissed them. And the second crisis was a secessionist movement in the southeast of Congo, the Katanga region, which was where a lot of the diamonds were stored in Congo. And Lumumba was frightened of both the mutiny and the secessionist movement. And that's why he actually called for the UN to come in and intervene. And then Lumumba got frustrated with the UN and eventually he did probably the biggest mistake that he could possibly do, which was ask for the Soviet Union to come in and intervene.
因此，卢蒙巴解雇了他们。第二次危机是刚果东南部的分离主义运动，即加丹加地区，刚果的大量钻石都储存在那里。卢蒙巴对兵变和分离主义运动都感到恐惧。这就是为什么他实际上呼吁联合国介入。然后，卢蒙巴对联合国感到沮丧，最终他可能犯了他所能犯下的最大错误，那就是请求苏联介入。
And that was his downfall. And this is when Eisenhower is the US president and Eisenhower a few years earlier had effectively pulled the curtain down on the British and French Imperial period at Suez. Yeah. But now he's, he's saying we've got to get rid of this guy.
这就是他的覆灭。当时艾森豪威尔是美国总统，几年前艾森豪威尔在苏伊士运河事件中实际上已经给英法帝国时期拉下了帷幕。是的。但现在他却说，我们必须除掉这个人。
I mean, he kind of basically, I mean, he, he, he effectively says that, doesn't he? He kind of says,
我的意思是，他基本上，我是说，他，他，他实际上就是这么说的，对吧？他有点像在说，
we've got to do whatever is necessary to get rid of. There's lots of declassified. There's lots of declassified MI6 and CIA documents that say, you know, ideally we should kill him. Yeah, because they saw the solo member as basically a second fidel castro essentially um somebody um who was um basically an anti-colonial leader just become a soviet state sorry so they have all these kind of mad schemes to get rid of of castro famously with exploding cigars and things and they send they send a guy called dr death of langley sydney gottlieb who has this wheeze to mix some poison that will simulate the effects of polio
我们必须采取一切必要手段除掉他。有很多解密的。有很多解密的军情六处和中央情报局文件说，你知道，理想情况下我们应该杀了他。是的，因为他们把卢蒙巴基本上看作第二个菲德尔·卡斯特罗，本质上是一个反殖民领袖，结果变成了一个苏联国家，抱歉，所以他们想出各种疯狂的计划来除掉卡斯特罗，比如著名的用雪茄爆炸之类的，他们派了一个叫兰利的“死亡博士”西德尼·戈特利布的家伙，他有个损招，就是在卢蒙巴的牙膏里混合一些能模拟小儿麻痹症症状的毒药。
in lemumbus toothpaste yeah yeah yeah they try that but um that didn't come because the um um i think the poison ran out of its sell-by date that's very cia behavior oh dear oh good so so yeah so the poison toothpaste doesn't work so so talk us through the horrible story about what how they get rid of him joseph ume Mobutu and Joseph Kasafubu, who, as I said earlier, was the president of Congo, the CIA in America and also the Belgian authorities saw both of them as suitable replacements for Patrice Lumumba. And so they got in touch with both of them.
是的，是的，他们试过了，但是，没有成功，因为，嗯，我想那毒药过保质期了。这非常符合中情局的风格。哦天哪，哦好吧。所以，所以，毒药牙膏没起作用，那么给我们讲讲他们是怎么除掉他的这个可怕的故事吧。约瑟夫·于姆·蒙博托和约瑟夫·卡萨武布，正如我刚才所说，他是刚果总统，美国的中央情报局以及比利时当局都认为这两人是取代帕特里斯·卢蒙巴的合适人选。于是他们联系了这两个人。
And Lumumba's rule as the prime minister of Congo lasted 64 days. So a couple of months after, with all the crisis, the military mutiny, but also the secession movements in Southeast lost control and was basically imprisoned after. And then a few months later, in January 1961, on his way to the Southeast, taken to the Southeast, he was brutally murdered and his body was um decomposed uh i think it's the right way to put it yeah and buried in an obscure place he was put in acid wasn't he was he dissolved in acid
卢蒙巴作为刚果总理的统治持续了64天。因此，在经历了所有危机、军事兵变以及东南部的分裂运动几个月后，他失去了控制，随后基本上被监禁。几个月后的1961年1月，在前往东南部途中，他被残酷谋杀，他的尸体被，嗯，腐烂了，我想这样说比较对吧，然后被埋在一个偏僻的地方。他被泡在酸里了，不是吗？他被溶解在酸里了。
basically yeah dissolved in acid yes and all that remained was a tooth that got found in the details i i can't bear anybody touching my nails it's's really... Don't you? I hate it. I really, really hate it. How did you get on when your parents were cutting your nails? I couldn't stand it. Even thinking about it makes me cringe. And Patrice Lumumba thought he had it bad. Well, they shoved splints underneath his nails.
基本上是的，溶解在酸里了，是的，剩下的只有一颗在细节中被找到的牙齿……我受不了任何人碰我的指甲，真的……你不觉得吗？我讨厌它。我真的、真的讨厌它。你父母给你剪指甲时是怎么过的？我简直无法忍受。一想到它我就觉得毛骨悚然。而帕特里斯·卢蒙巴还以为他的遭遇已经够惨了呢。好吧，他们把夹板塞进他的指甲下面。
Yeah, yeah. They tortured him. Just horrible, horrible, horrible. Yeah. Anyway, enough of that. But the crisis doesn't actually end there. So after Lumumba was assassinated, Mobutsu and Kasafubu still had to deal with the secession movement
对，对。他们折磨他。简直是太可怕、太可怕、太可怕了。好了，不说这个了。但危机并没有就此结束。因此，在卢蒙巴被暗杀后，蒙博托和卡萨武布仍然必须应对东南部的分离运动，
in the Southeast, Katanga separation movement. So they had to quell that movement. But a few years after that, they also had to deal with a secession movement in a place called Stanleyville. So Stanleyville, which is in the east of the country, was where Lumumba had most of his support. So Stanleyville in 1964 declared independence from congo and this led to a terrible civil war in which um joseph mabutu as now a a military lieutenant general had to quell that that secession movement and tens of thousands of people were killed and then by 1965 uh when when that stanleyville secession movement was was finally suppressed mabutsu basically dismissed
加丹加分裂运动。所以他们必须平息那场运动。但在那之后的几年里，他们还必须应对一个叫斯坦利维尔的地方的分离运动。因此，斯坦利维尔位于该国东部，是卢蒙巴拥有最多支持的地方。因此，1964年的斯坦利维尔宣布脱离刚果独立，这导致了一场可怕的内战，其中约瑟夫·蒙博托作为当时的一名陆军中将，不得不平息那场分离运动，数万人丧生。到了1965年，当斯坦利维尔的分离运动最终被镇压时，蒙博托基本上解除了
joseph kasafubu the president and also also the prime minister at that time and declared himself as the new president of Congo in November 1965. And a few months or six months later, Mobutu accused four ministers from the previous administration of being corrupt and of basically being treacherous. and four of those ministers including um the previous prime minister uh were publicly executed so mabuti kind of becomes the paradigm of the despotic african president so he's he's he's nicknamed the dinosaur um he i mean he's what he's he's plunders billions and spends it all on kind of Concorde trips to Paris he builds a Versailles doesn't he
总统约瑟夫·卡萨武布以及当时的总理的职务，并在1965年11月宣布自己为刚果的新总统。几个月后，或者说六个月后，蒙博托指控前政府的四名部长腐败，基本上是叛国。其中四名部长，包括前总理，被公开处决。所以蒙博托某种程度上成了专制非洲总统的典型，所以他被昵称为“恐龙”。我的意思是，他掠夺了数十亿美元，并把它们全部花在去巴黎的协和飞机旅行上，他建了一座凡尔赛宫，不是吗？
he builds a Versailles in the jungle the rumble in the jungle exactly and the interesting thing about Mobutu is that he sort of combines many sort of factors within the sort of the post-colonial leader. So on the one hand, he had a very strong relationship with America and with
他在丛林里建了一座凡尔赛宫，森林对决，没错。关于蒙博托，有趣的是，他在后殖民领导人的各类因素中融合了许多特点。一方面，他与美国以及许多其他西方力量保持着非常紧密的关系，
many other Western forces. But on the other hand, he developed a called uh mobutuism and authenticity so authenticity so he changed the name of of congo to zaire um in 1971 and he also changed the currency to zaire and also the river the river congo to the river zaire and and he changed his name as well from Joseph Desiree Mobutu to Mobutu Sese Seko. And during that time, during his reign, he made it forbidden for Catholic priests and Catholic bishops to baptize any child with a European name. So all the people in Zaire needed to have African names. And he was doing all of this whilst visiting Paris, being great friends with Nixon. But isn't that a sort of pattern though, Tom,
但另一方面，他也发展了一种被称为“蒙博托主义”和“真实性”的东西。因此是“真实性”，所以在1971年，他将刚果的名字改为了扎伊尔，他还将货币改为了扎伊尔，把刚果河改成了扎伊尔河，他还把自己的名字从约瑟夫·德西雷·蒙博托改为了蒙博托·塞塞·塞科。在那期间，在他的统治期间，他禁止天主教神父和天主教主教用欧洲名字为任何儿童洗礼。因此扎伊尔的所有人都必须拥有非洲名字。他在做这一切的同时还访问巴黎，与尼克松成为好朋友。但这难道不是一种模式吗，汤姆，
that you see this with... I mean, Tom and I were talking before we started the broadcast, actually, about Jean-Bédel Bacassa, the Central African Republic, who makes himself emperor. He has a coronation based on that of Napoleon. Or indeed Idi Amin. Amin Idi Amin was in the King's African Rifles. He was a cook.
你从……我的意思是，汤姆和我在广播开始前其实还在谈论让-贝德尔·博萨卡，中非共和国的皇帝，他把自己加冕为皇帝。他的加冕典礼是基于拿破仑的典礼。或者还有伊迪·阿明。阿明，伊迪·阿明曾在国王非洲步枪团服役。他是个厨师。
He played rugby. Last King of Scotland. Players used to hit him with a hammer on the head before games to get him excited. But yes, he claims that he's the last King of Scotland. He gives himself the title Con conqueror of the British Empire. So on the one hand, these guys are very anti-colonial, anti-Western. But they're clearly completely shaped by that legacy
他打橄榄球。苏格兰的末代国王。比赛前队员们用锤子砸他的头让他兴奋起来。但是是的，他声称自己是苏格兰的末代国王。他给自己封了个头衔叫大英帝国的征服者。因此，一方面，这些人非常反殖民、反西方。但他们显然完全被这种历史遗产所塑造，
and they can't rid themselves. They have to constantly prove every day that they are better than the western exploiters and they do that by using western kind of formulae and and flying on concord and giving themselves invented western titles and things yeah mabuchu's favorite book uh and apparently the book that he was able to recite was um machiavellius the Prince. Wow. He could recite it. He'd learned it.
而且他们无法摆脱。他们每天都必须不断证明自己比西方剥削者更好，他们通过使用西方的某种公式、乘坐协和飞机以及给自己授予虚构的西方头衔等方式来做到这一点。是的，蒙博托最喜欢的书，显然也是他能背诵的书，是尼可罗·马基雅维利的《君主论》。哇。他能背诵它。他把它背下来了。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Apparently he could recite large passages from it. It's quite a short book, I think. Yeah. Even so, though. Quite impressive. Yeah, yeah. Quite impressive.
对，对，对。据说他能背诵其中的大量段落。我想那是一本很短的书。是的。即便如此。相当令人印象深刻。是的，是的。相当令人印象深刻。
I guess, I mean, this is absolutely a whistle-stop tour around an entire continent. I mean, I wonder i wonder just now there is talk about um china and whether you feel that perhaps there is a a process of recolonization going on with china people do talk about that do you think that's exaggerated or not i i don't think it's necessarily exaggerated because China is definitely investing a lot in Africa, in African infrastructure. And it is true that there are many Chinese people that are moving into Africa, working with African businesses, working with African engineers. So I do think that that is a significant fact of 21st century Africa. The issue is the extent to which this is comparable to colonialism
我想，我的意思是，这绝对是一次环游整个大陆的闪电之旅。我的意思是，我想知道，就在现在，人们在谈论中国，你是否觉得中国可能正在进行一个重新殖民化的过程？人们确实在谈论这个，你认为这被夸大了吗？我不认为这必然被夸大了，因为中国确实在非洲、在非洲基础设施上投入了大量资金。而且确实有很多中国人移居非洲，与非洲企业合作，与非洲工程师合作。所以我确实认为这是21世纪非洲的一个重要事实。问题在于这在多大程度上可以与殖民主义相提并论，
during the European colonialism. If we have a very sort of expansive definition of colonialism, then it is definitely comparable. But if our definition of colonialism is more limited to the European example, then I think there are significant differences between what's going on in China and what occurred during the 19th and early 20th century.
在欧洲殖民主义时期。如果我们对殖民主义采取非常广泛的定义，那么它绝对是可以相提并论的。但如果我们对殖民主义的定义更加局限于欧洲的例子，那么我认为中国正在发生的事情与19世纪和20世纪初发生的事情之间存在显著差异。
Let me ask you a question about the process of decolonization from the viewpoint now. When we look at it now, I mean, we've listed what happened in the Congo. Obviously, there are so many countries where the British or the French congratulated themselves on having set up these incredibly healthy multi-party democracies, and then within two years or five years, that had come crashing down.
让我从现在的角度问你一个关于去殖民化进程的问题。当我们现在回看它时，我的意思是，我们列举了刚果发生的事情。显然有许多国家，英国或法国曾为自己建立了这些极其健康的多元民主政体而沾沾自喜，然后不出两年或五年，这些政体就崩溃了。
Do you think that there was any plausible way that, in general, the process of European withdrawal from Africa could have been better handled? Or do you think, really, it was a kind of, given the nature of those regimes given the the weakness of civil society in some of those countries given that the europeans had treated the africans so badly do you think that was always inevitable um i i wouldn't say inevitable but i i would say it would have been quite difficult to successfully manage um a process of decolonization. I think partly because many, many Africans within the particular parameters of the nation state came from different ethnic groups and different cultural traditions. So creating a nation state out of many of these
你认为欧洲撤出非洲的进程总体上有没有可能以更好的方式处理？或者你认为，真的，考虑到这些政权的性质，考虑到其中一些国家公民社会的软弱，考虑到欧洲人对非洲人太坏了，你认为这是不可避免的吗？我不会说这是不可避免的，但我会说成功管理去殖民化进程将会相当困难。我认为部分原因是，民族国家特定参数内的许多非洲人来自不同的族群和不同的文化传统。因此，从许多这些领土中创建一个民族国家，
territories was always going to be very difficult. I think one example which has personal resonance for me is Nigeria. So at the time Nigeria became an independent state, there were over 250 different ethnic groups within the country, and the country was largely split into three territories. So the largely Muslim North, which was ruled by the Hausa Fulani ethnic group, and also the largely Christian South, which was bifurcated between the Igbo East and the largely Yoruba West. And less than 10 years after Nigeria became an independent state, there was the Biafran War, which led to the death of two or three million people. So I do think that it was always going to be difficult
注定是非常困难的。我认为对我个人而言有共鸣的一个例子是尼日利亚。因此，在尼日利亚成为独立国家时，国内有超过250个不同的族群，该国大致分裂为三个领土。主要是穆斯林的北部，由豪萨-富拉尼族群统治；还有主要是基督教的南部，在伊博东部和主要是约鲁巴西部之间一分为二。在尼日利亚成为独立国家不到十年后，就爆发了比亚法拉战争，导致两三百万人的死亡。所以我确实认为，要成功管理去殖民化，
to successfully manage decolonisation. And I think a big part of that isn't just cruelty by the Europeans or oppression by the Europeans or incompetence by the Europeans, though this was definitely a factor, but also the fact that many of these countries were largely fictions, which sort of elided the important cultural and ethnic differences within the population. Which I suppose maps onto the idea that a lot of the ideological impetus for decolonization comes from Europe. The very idea of a of a nation the state being
这总是很困难的。我认为其中的很大一部分原因不仅在于欧洲人的残酷、欧洲人的压迫或欧洲人的无能，尽管这绝对是一个因素，还在于许多这些国家在很大程度上是虚构的，它们抹杀了人口中重要的文化和民族差异。我想这与去殖民化的许多意识形态动力来自欧洲的观点相吻合。国家作为一个独立实体的观念正是这种现象的表现，
independent is is a manifestation of that yeah definitely yeah it's fascinating i i such a great discussion thanks ever so much for it we haven't even scratched the surface have we yes no well i think i think i mean i think you know as with so many of these um discussions we've had it kind of opens up all kinds of um prospects for future episodes i mean we haven't talked about rhodesia or south africa at all which are kind of huge huge topics so i think these are you know things to come back to don't you don't definitely definitely absolutely if tom will um if tom will find time to come back and and maybe we can finally talk about what the importance of world war ii tom holland yes yes i'll keep that in mind as well all right who cares about world war ii yeah well your brother
是的，绝对是的。这太迷人了，我非常喜欢这次讨论，非常感谢。我们甚至还没有触及皮毛，不是吗？是的，不，好吧，我想，我的意思是，我想你知道，就像我们进行过的许多这些讨论一样，它为未来的节目开辟了各种前景。我的意思是，我们根本没有谈论罗得西亚或南非，这些都是非常巨大的话题，所以我认为这些是以后可以回顾的事情，不是吗？绝对，绝对，绝对，如果汤姆愿意抽时间回来，也许我们最终可以谈谈第二次世界大战的重要性，汤姆·霍兰，是的，是的，我也会记住这一点的。好吧，谁在乎第二次世界大战呢？是的，好吧，你的兄弟，
yes he does um brilliant thanks so much tom thank you tom thank you so much thank you bye-bye bye everybody everybody. Thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at rest is history pod.com. That's rest is history pod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，他会的。太棒了，非常感谢汤姆，谢谢你，汤姆，非常感谢，再见，大家再见。感谢收听《历史的其余部分》，获取独家剧集、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区。请访问 rest is history pod.com 注册。这就是 rest is history pod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。